Hey welcome aboard this morning I'm
going to the Intrepid Sea Air and Space
Museum yeah there's some people up there
so we're in lower Manhattan now and
let's do this
Lauren Hudson Street which is actually
several blocks in from the Hudson River
I don't know why they call it Hudson
Street maybe the Hudson used to be right
here and then we just kept filling in
the land because Manhattan real estate
is so valuable just had a fixed land to
the land that's already there then it's
like printing money that's what I think
they really did notice some in the
street that reminds me of Chuck nice
it's just like Chuck nice hi Chuck nice
Hey
okay all right
they do need a ride I didn't know you
needed a ride who is this oh this and I
picked him up earlier in the head my
friend right here
that's nothing now we're just riding
around picking up random strangers so
where are you going totally Intrepid Sea
Air and Space Museum it's very cool
because I just happen to be going to the
same place you are lying
no man haven't seen you in trouble cuz
I'm headed where you're headed Ashley
you know I'm homeless no please always
where we need to do what any time
exactly most people in New York are
actually homeless and they don't even
know it tiny low apartments they have no
idea that they're actually homeless
nobody wants to be entertaining little
apartments that's why these streets are
filled with people often that's right
because they don't stay they don't stand
no my favorite homeless joke what's that
I'm so broke I can't even pay attention
intrepid sea air and you should be used
be intrepid and then he said we got we
got more we got more going on here then
than what meets the eye right because
the Intrepid of course is at aircraft
carrier and its relevance to space is of
course it actually picked up several of
the capsules that landed in the Pacific
yes yes so it has a legacy with the
space program okay so when they would
shoot because before the shuttles you
forced a week before you could land you
know on an airport basically the guys
would come out of orbit and they would
be descending by parachute in a capsule
and then they'd land right in the ocean
and wait around till they get picked up
you know that's that's gotta be a little
scary yes a little primitive to games
you think about it yeah and they had to
have some kind of homing beacon because
the ocean
they're called binoculars there was no
little GPS back then no home there's no
cell phone towers it's pretty easy to
calculate the coordinates of the drop
you know where they're approximately
where they're supposed to be and there's
huge parachutes so they got this okay
yeah and they have radar too but it's ok
so the way so they track the radar on
the lands the thing itself has has
balloons you know to keep it afloat the
otherwise if you would just sink and so
it could be filled with water right so
yeah so the intrepid has this legacy and
so they folded that legacy into it as a
as a memorial to the Second World War
okay and the intrepid was actually hit
by a kamikaze plane no so this thing's
got all kinds of bad I mean it's it's
it's it's it's been around the block the
thing so wait a minute a kamikaze
actually yes getting out here rooting
for the Japs no but I'm just saying like
you would think that if you crashed a
plane into an aircraft carrier you would
have done enough damage where it didn't
get to confession so what member it's a
graphic area is a military machine it's
a it's a battle-hardened
vessel so the the the kamikazes would
aim for the deck which had access down
through where other parts of the ship
would be but if you just if you get if
you just hit where the planes land
you'll damage where the planes land but
you're not gonna sink to share now this
did this yet no there we gotta hit key
spots
Aragog making kamikazes as very
ineffective means of battle tactic
basically well especially since you lose
your pilot every time you do it not to
mention a plane but exactly so of course
that was a late war tactic by the
Japanese desperate yes a desperation
with Craig